[Music]
all right welcome back to another
another um regular episode
we're going around the room right now
we're gonna find out hey what do you
guys think is the is old enough for kids
come on i'm [ __ ] around no no
no we're we're talking about nothing
clever justine
a guy a guy left his jeep at a at a
dealership to get his oil changed well
then
uh that guy is getting sued because
somebody died
involving his car after he wasn't even
there
what the [ __ ] how would the cars how did
they die like what the [ __ ] so i'll tell
you what happened so
there was a of course
a 19 year old mechanic
he's trying to change the oil that's old
enough for kisses do you think he's old
enough for kisses 19 yeah he was trying
to suck on the oils he is he certified
mechanic though 19 is too old
[Laughter]
he removes his foot from the clutch
he doesn't know how to drive stick oh
[ __ ]
you gotta teach people to drive stick
man yeah right
jeep jumps up
kills a married 42 year old father of
four why and lifelong mechanic oh
another mechanic yeah another mechanic
uh so the 19 year old's in the in the in
the car right vehicle jumps up kills the
42 year old father for a mechanic oh my
god and they sue the guy for having a
stick shift guy dies instantly
and then um
they're they're suing the the owner of
the car not the kid who killed them no
not the 19 year old what ground
and who's suing
so how are you gonna sue your customer
for [ __ ] giving your business yeah
that's
that's gaslighting because the accident
happened at work involved two employees
you can't sue the boss in that situation
according well can you sue the employee
according to the legal standard
uh
what do you mean who would sue the
employees
the family who died like the family who
had the dead father right that's the
party that's suing right
uh yes so why don't they sue the
employee who killed the other mechanic
they say they can't because they of this
legal standard that is in this
particular area so they just have to get
somebody then is that what this is about
because the jeep if the jeep was a gun
you can't sue the guy that pulled the
trigger that's crazy but you can try
but not if it's at work i think that's
the thing because it's at work yeah what
the so what's the actual charge so let's
say you work at a gun store and someone
pull the trigger you can't you can't uh
sue the guy at the gun store or pull the
trigger like a gun manager
shot like the employee or something yeah
an employee shot another employee that's
crazy that's bizarre so the the attorney
says that there the person responsible
is the owner of the car
and so yeah so the reporters are like
you're suing the owner of the car who's
getting his oil changed who did nothing
in this case and he's like i have to i
have to because of the technicalities
so someone's kind of serious she wants
money probably this is america we it's
our heritage this is what we do it's our
birthright
someone's getting sued man it's our
birthright i'm [ __ ]
blown by that that's ridiculous so
[ __ ] that's really fun if you haven't
been sued you're not really american
why don't they sue [ __ ] jeep or
something
right poor innocent guy nobody in
america shoot his jeep
that's true this attorney's gonna be
very popular listen to this he says when
you hand your car over to anybody
including the valet or the person at the
service desk at your local dealership
you better be able to trust that person
what [ __ ] it's just an oil change so
don't trust this business is what he's
saying this business is a piece of [ __ ]
was it it was a jeep dealership or was
it just like a mechanic that he brought
his jeep when you're sitting in this
channel and asking [ __ ] like that it
sounds like a it sounds like a jiffy
lube was it a grand cherokee or was it a
wrangler sport
it's a dealership
you pieces
you mcbee
[ __ ] mcb what's the actual jeep
dealership that's crazy yeah because
yeah where else do you drop your jeep
off where else can you right it's an
official dealership who can you trust
anymore huh yeah you can't even trust a
dealership who the [ __ ] gonna drop off
their cars to get worked on anymore i
think a 19 year old secretly wanted to
always wanted to kill that 42 year old
[Laughter]
stick shift here's my chance
yeah people use that excuse a lot these
days like oh i don't know how to drive
stick it's like he knows so i ran over
five children yeah i don't have a drive
steak you know
i'm a mechanic that doesn't know how to
drive stick whoops yeah not a very good
mechanic huh
yeah how do you not know how to drive
stick and you're a mechanic though
that's pretty i guess 19 but still god
damn
well yeah 19 year old knowing how to
drive stick today is rare probably but
don't you gotta go to like drive stick
at mechanic school yeah yeah if you're
gonna be a mechanic because you because
he could technically fix a stick
yeah but but how does he get it out of
like
first gear
and why'd they leave it to him if he
doesn't know how to drive sticks
everybody knows the hardest part about
learning how to drive stick is getting
out of first gear yeah you know what i
mean yep so first go what the [ __ ] was
this guy doing well
maybe he's on
an incline and then you hit the clutch
and at what speed is this [ __ ]
going you know on like a flat like it's
not like a mechanic's like always
working on a [ __ ] hill or anything
you know what i mean it's just flat so
even if you get out at first
you got to be flooring it or something
like that to like hit somebody or it
could be the dude the 43 year old is in
between the car
and the wall
and he goes hey can i walk through here
yeah like sure i'm just going to check
on whatever and then boom it jumps in so
what happened to the guy from star trek
right because that was a jeep too
remember his car started rolling yeah
his car started rolling and then it was
just like oh
yeah that was sad oh yeah anton yelkin
yeah that was uh why are we assuming
this mechanic shop is an all-male
mechanic shop by the way that's true it
could be a female of a cat 19 year old
that's not a dry stick only females in
our drop sticks
a woman driver is what you're saying
it's your theory sounds to me like this
is a women's mechanic
they're very popular they're rising
right world's first woman mechanic shop
has a horrible accident
that sounds like it has a ring to it
kind of not bad
um
i think i think probably 16 is old
enough for kisses in detroit
if i had to guess
i bet this law came out because of the
huge ass car industry there oh yeah dude
so they're like we can't have any
liability for any accidents that happen
for like car [ __ ]
definitely well it's detroit yeah
so imagine you have our dealership in
detroit and you're going to get sued by
your employees
make sure it's all set up so you're good
that's the best place to own a
dealership then you can never get in
trouble and everyone's leaving
yeah
you can't drink the tap water there
either though right that's what i hear
oh yeah that flint honest on the track
michigan yeah
yes sir
i think they just leave detroit that's
the problem with the story
[Laughter]
detroit should get sued what journalists
wrote this news for detroit
like fox fox detroit
dude i bet fox in every other state's
talking [ __ ] about fox
i like all this poor branch you have to
go work at fox detroit have you guys
been to detroit it's pretty crazy like
i've seen boarded up skyscrapers
yeah and about like there's just
abandoned neighborhoods not even homes
like springs
yeah several homes just plywood on the
windows graffiti is just like mad homes
just
vacant wasn't it isn't there like a
housing crisis here why not ship the
people that's over there people here
don't like to move out of state for some
reason
especially in this room yeah see people
rather be homeless in california than
have a home in this sunshine dude we
love the sunshine well the weather sucks
to be homeless in detroit yeah there's
homes there that if you occupy and pay
the tax and the utilities it's yours
you get a free house yeah there's no one
to kick you out there's no no one has
that job there it's so dead like they're
downtown where their skyscrapers are you
could probably lay on in the middle of
the street and no one will run you over
for five minutes
it's dead it's a whole five minutes
like it's like let's try it out it's
like [ __ ] loading those newspapers
like that tumbleweeds yeah
well the joke a couple years ago was
like you could go to detroit with like
100 bucks and like be a real estate
haven or something like that
yeah cause like there were several
houses like two bucks and shipped so you
could have like five homes yeah or a
hundred but then it's all dilapidated
[ __ ] so yeah you don't want that yes is
that because uh what the oa recession
thing the i mean the no the car industry
left and that was the only thing they
had and they never recovered after that
they just slowly all of them were there
like four so every recession they had
just hit them extra hard so i guess what
we're trying to say to this father of
four who died is why didn't you leave
detroit
sometimes you have to victim blame and
this is one of those times
good job to a 19 year old for working at
a safe spot for him you know what man
that's
if i could travel back in time to the
moment the thing's about to hit him i
wouldn't say get out of the way i would
say get out of detroit
get out of detroit he's like huh
he's like but you know it costs money to
move right
let's see i heard vegas is cheap
i only talk to you about detroit because
even when it was not this it was still
shitty to me
oh you went back before it was all
boarded up like we've been back there
like several times for shows and
everyone was always super awesome he
owns a neighborhood over there in a
skyscraper he's 19 million dollars yeah
it's part of my net worth
there's an area that they're trying to
revive and stuff we saw were just like
oh wow that's cool and then like you're
like they're like like a hipster coffee
shop and you're looking at a boarded up
skyscraper that's the key man
as long as it becomes hipster it can
look as shitty as you want this is what
we have to investigate we have to
interview somebody from detroit and we
have to ask them all our questions about
detroit so they can answer and you know
you know myth bust any of the stuff that
we're saying their forefathers children
we could talk to it's just well it's
just the hmong community that lives like
around detroit like in the suburbs of
detroit but no one actually lives i
don't think they're in the city you're
trying to get clint eastwood on the show
yeah gran torino
that's what i really want so we could
yell racial slurs at us
i like to make b a clint eastwood
you want to bring him back to that era
we're gonna need to give people context
oh no we're out of yeah
sign up for the patreon [ __ ]
now